في عام 2016، بدأت جيسيكا فورد تلاحظ
ارتعاشًا لا إراديًا في يدها اليمنى
واستمر لعدة أشهر قبل أن تذهب إلى
الطبيب وتم تشخيص إصابتها
بمرض باركنسون لفترة من الوقت، واعتقدت نوعًا ما
أن ذلك سينهي
حياتي حقًا أو يغيرها بشكل كبير جدًا هذا
العام.  تقول البالغة من العمر عامًا إن الأمر استغرق حوالي عام
لضبط موقفها تجاه المرض وإيجاد
دواء يساعد في علاج
أعراضها طوال الوقت، في حين أن
الرقص النشط يغذي روحي وأنا أحب الحركة
وأحب الموسيقى، وهي الآن قادرة على مشاركة
هذا الحب مع الآخرين الذين يعيشون  مع
نفس المرض بالنسبة لي، كان الأمر أشبه باللحظة التي
وصلت فيها هذا الشيء عبر بريدي الإلكتروني الذي قمت
بالتسجيل فيه، وهو برنامج يسمى الرقص مع
مرض باركنسون، وهو برنامج مدته خمسة أسابيع تقدمه جامعة
Northwestern Medicine وJoffrey
Ballet في شيكاغو، وجميع التمارين الرياضية مفيدة
للأشخاص المصابين بمرض باركنسون الدكتور داني.
يقول فيجا إن دروس الرقص تعالج
المرض ككل، ولا تساعد
أجساد مرضاه فحسب، بل تساعد عقولهم أيضًا. يعد
التعلم ومحاولة تذكر الخطوات في
روتين الرقص أمرًا جيدًا للعمل مع
الذاكرة وتحسين التفكير، وقد رأينا
فوائد في الأشخاص الذين يصفون
التحسن في  القلق والتعب،
شعر جسدي براحة أكبر، وشعرت بمزيد من
التفاعل، وأنت تعلم أن الموقف العقلي بأكمله
كان
مرتفعًا جدًا بعد أن كنت بعيدًا عن الناس
أثناء جائحة كوفيد-19، يقول فورد
إنه من الجيد أيضًا أن أكون اجتماعيًا مرة أخرى، ما زلت
كذلك.  مبتسمًا ماذا يخبرك ذلك
لدقيقة صحية أنا آندي جايثر